when churches begin to drink the
kool-aid of social justice
as interpreted by the ideological left
it's not just troublesome it's the
beginning of the slippery slope i
wouldn't even argue
the biggest problem in america right now
is not even moral relativism or cultural
decadence or even big government
the problem in america is a lukewarm
church
it's a church in a religious community
that's drinking the kool-aid
and we're bowie we're bowing at the
altar of race
somehow race just became god do you
realize that there are pastors that
speak more about race than they do about
jesus or moses
or abraham so race and sexuality
just became idols and we are worshiping
on the altar
of the gods created by culture
so how do you blend that with what i
know you believe which is a separation
between church and state
what what should the role of government
uh of religion
in state be then is is it just up to the
individuals should the state be
fostering it somehow
and i know you've done this before and
just let me for the audience say
that separation of church and state that
jeffersonian letter
to that amazing church i we we have
totally
taken this on the ideological left they
have taken that
out of context and it's church should
not have a place in the public sphere
quite the contrary please do your
diligence on this
jefferson is writing saying government
should never have the right we have to
separate
government from thinking it even has the
notion or the right for a moment
to quelch silence limit to somehow
hinder obstruct
the free expression of worship and faith
so jefferson is saying
government better not touch faith and
religion
not the other way around not that
religion and faith shouldn't touch the
public's fear
we have a place in the public sphere
people of faith even that beautiful
faithful expression
george washington referenced it at the
latter portion of his
presidency about this commitment to
faith is the backbone
of this new american experience abraham
lincoln reiterated that
david dwight david eisenhower again
ronald reagan of course
elevated it to the stratosphere yes
so i do believe that we and right now
that's not happening right now
government is telling me
that i have to change my theology in
order to accommodate
cultural shifts that are general
specific
i mean are you kidding me there are laws
as we speak
including the equality act which is not
equal
other attempts to diminish my ability to
speak what i believe is
truth eternal truth truth that stems
from
from a natural law from a
a moral compass that's way beyond your
generation and my generation
that is the backbone of civilization and
somehow i'm supposed to sacrifice truth
on the altar of political or cultural
or generational expediency so yes there
is a separation but to protect
the free expression of faith how much of
your time as a pastor is devoted to that
i mean basically inoculating your
congregation
from the whims of the day because i hear
i hear from all sorts of faith leaders
that social justice is creeping into
their synagogues creeping into their
churches
etc and again even the notion of social
justice i believe in biblical justice
which uh biblical justice which is micah
6 8 do justice love mercy walk humbly
it's psalm 89 14.
it's luke chapter 4. so i believe in
biblical justice
and biblical justice is an extension of
righteousness
so when all these things happened last
year i looked at my church here's an
interesting thing
my church is 40 white which is code word
for caucasian
40 black which is african-american and
20
latino and asian i am blessed to oversee
a very beautifully multi-ethnically
diverse congregation
when everything happened last year i
i've approached the podium and i said
ladies and gentlemen
we will biblically speaking address
any and all vestiges of bigotry and
we'll do it with the authority of
scripture but we won't do it
in the name of any movement that runs
calendar to the values that you and i
hold near and dear
we will not do it in any movement's name
as a christian we're gonna do it in the
name of jesus
so again we can separate but when
churches begin to drink the kool-aid
of social justice as interpreted by the
ideological left
it's not just troublesome it's the
beginning of the slippery slope i would
even argue
the biggest problem in america right now
is not even moral relativism or cultural
decadence or even big government
the problem in america is a lukewarm
church
it's a church in a religious community
that's drinking the kool-aid
and we're bowie we're bowing at the
altar of race
somehow race just became god do you
realize that there are pastors that
speak more about race than they do about
jesus or moses
or abraham so race and sexuality
just became idols and we are worshipping
on the altar
of the gods created by culture created
by individuals
who are inclined to a morally
relativistic worldview who
who embrace anarchy and chaos
and we're bowing to this and that's the
problem in america so what do you think
the flaw was
in the in the leadership of either the
churches or
the temples or probably in the mosques
as well
that allowed the people that are
supposed to be the leaders like you the
pastors
to allow it in you you think i was it
was it the fault of the pastors for
allowing it i mean if enough people if
enough people are coming to them with
something
it's leadership it always does it always
falls on leadership
it always falls on leadership and and we
are all and i'm
part of the collective leadership motif
here we're all to blame
we are we need to repent it's a second
chronicles 7 14 moment
it we need to repent we really do we've
permitted this and by the way it's this
like like like like like like like like
like like
we are more committed to likes and
followers
than we are to truth and when we're more
committed to likes and followers and we
are to truth
we begin to water down truth acquiesce
truth surrender truth
and then our children will reap the
consequences of our complacency
today's complacency is tomorrow's
captivity and right now we are
complacent
and we're comfortable and it's a shame
because our children are watching and
they're going to pay the price
of secular totalitarianism of socialism
of communism of anti-science
there's no biology human physiology
doesn't matter
science doesn't matter we're going to
reap the consequences of
our activities in our generation yeah i
can now see that
my audience will get why i wanted to
have you on because you're hitting so
many of the topics that
that i talk about all the time i i want
to talk to you about immigration
uh in just a bit but what else did you
find in this past year
that people were coming to you because i
do sense what you hinted at there
about a spiritual awakening i've been
saying for a while you know
at a micro level i think an atheist or
an absolutely perfect secular view of
the world can work
meaning individual people can do that i
think it takes
a certain type of person but i think
it's possible but at the macro level it
just simply can't work it can't work and
even the atheists and agnostics
who i have some as friends when we have
these conversations these sort of
metaphysical and cosmic conversations of
the big picture
uh i call it the extension of the big
bang it's still happening
and they even allude to the fact many of
them even some of them that are pretty
prominent have referenced the fact
that precise for society to function we
need
a set of morals more a value system
that has a viable religious spiritual
component to it they don't negate that
it's part of who we are as human beings
it's part of our
spiritual genome uh without a doubt
so yes i have seen in the past year not
only spiritual hunger
but i have seen likewise this
fear of what's next of the immediate
sacrifice of our ability to express
ourselves spiritually
as it pertains to faith and religion at
the drop of a dime
how we have surrendered so much and how
government
is so much more powerful than we ever
ever would have conceived or thought of
yeah
that sort of that fear is there are you
shocked
are you shocked how quickly everyone
just kind of put their hands up and said
okay i'm not going to go to church
anymore i'm not going to go to temple
anymore i'm not going to go to work
anymore et cetera et cetera
that it i am blown away intellectually
emotionally spiritually
we just surrendered everything i mean
everything and it wasn't even proof
meaning
it was theoretical back then right we
had no idea so you could argue because
we had no idea we had the right i don't
know if you had the right
i really don't and so here's what i
discovered
they that my constitution is only as
good
and viable as long as we don't have an
emergency
so my god-given rights come to an
end when a virus or any other government
deemed emergency yeah whatever is that
yeah they're not they're not absolute
they're not eternal
because government can take away scary
times
it's revealing it's exposing some
weaknesses in the in the collective of
what we call the american experience
and the global human experience for that
matter if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell